hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to a clip
from the fresh and fit
podcast with the better bachelor um it's
titled girls want attractive men
i actually really enjoy
watching the better bachelor i think
he's very logical so i get excited when
i see him
on this show before i start do not
forget
i'm just going to tell you guys to
subscribe if you're here if you like my
content
hit that subscribe button
[Music]
what's the best mindset for guys now
because i feel like definitely you have
your stance we have our stance and it's
kind of
it's the same thing i think it's just
how much effort you want to put into it
overall guys do want one thing at the
end of the day
all right yeah peace quiet and some you
know better than fun
right so what's the best mindset you
could say for a guy coming up now
right now if if i were to say if i
if i if i were going to enter the market
okay when men look at women what do they
look at
i mean what's the first thing that
catches your eye about a woman
oh i know i i was cheating i know you're
looking yeah no no no what's the first
thing uh
i mean looks of course but what about
let's say you catch her across the club
is it her eye color
yes okay right what else and the breast
is okay
what do women like on men i would say
from a visual standpoint right away
checks
chest shoulders height height
above all else well but let's i've gone
to the gym for a long time i've not
grown an age
but let's keep it in the realm of what
we can control right if a man wants a
good looking women
a woman women like wide shoulders women
like big biceps
women like 1.6 ratio that's it the v
ratio right
from width down to your waist women like
asses too
women like thighs quads big big thighs
too hit the gym
number one just hit the gym and i say
that just for you
like i'm not you know going out there on
the market but i'm hitting the gym like
a madman because i look at the
in the mirror and i go i look like a
pillow like i know it you know
and and also you know covet did i don't
think women
care as much about looks as men do
if a guy is funny has a good personality
you have a lot in common
other than the height that's a big thing
for girls but muscles
i don't think our i haven't found to be
a big
huge thing for women it's more they care
more about career they care more about
um you know ambition
other than height that's that's the one
caveat women do care about height
i would say to more than they should
pretty heavily uh um
hit the overweight so get your weight
down get your health right do it for you
but there's a great bonus
women like it yep then hey uh do what
you can about your looks like if if um
if you wear glasses like when you go
clubbing you wear your glasses no not
only on the show why not
because i'm blind wait yeah but why
don't you wear it oh yeah i mean yeah
man it improves your aesthetics when you
don't wear them right so you go to
contacts
uh if you got a weak chin which i kind
of do
um you grow in the beard if you can now
guys if you can't grow in a beard
rogaine there you go you know the hair
little tip
you put it down here it helped me fill
in two ball patches on each one
a little bit of rogue this is not
medical advice i'm just saying that you
probably can do this there you go so
um a little bit rogaine on your face and
then when you trim your beard
square it out a little bit it'll give
you a women wear makeup there's nothing
wrong with you
squaring up your jaw a little bit giving
yourself a little bit more of a jaw yeah
uh if you're starting to thin a little
bit go just
yeah yeah just like just rip the cord
off you know there's nothing worse than
sitting there with some spray or some
crap
just shave it this is low maintenance if
you ride motorcycle like i do
no more motorcycle helmet here you just
and pretty
so um so it and and that's from the
physical
from the emotional you got to be right
with yourself you got to be right with
yourself you got to love yourself
more than anybody else in the world ever
possibly could
i am the most important person in my
life i mean beside my family let's be
honest
and my dog um i love myself more than
anybody else in the world
i don't think that that is stupid nor is
it narcissistic you just gotta
understand there's only gonna be one
person that definitely has your back
a hundred percent until the day you die
which is you that's you as roloff says
you're
always a point of origin shout out women
can
sniff out if a guy isn't confident i
i agree with this so
so you you take care of your you take
care of your facilities where you say
you know what i'm happy by myself
i'm successful by myself um i don't feel
like i'm needy i don't feel like i'm
alone
and if you do if you are missing that
go get a pet go make some friends and
and
the way you make friends for a lot of
you guys to say but i don't have any
friends and i
find a hobby you love and go get
involved in it into a club but here's
the thing through all
of that you've got to be able to talk to
strangers yeah you got to be like i
don't know
when did we meet a couple hours ago
right
right but if we went out clubbing we'd
have laughs we'd have a good time we go
talk to strangers we do
we don't know each other i mean yeah
very nice gentlemen but but it's not
like we've been friends for our whole
life
yeah when you can do that with anybody
then when you go into a pub or whatever
you just and i truly believe that this
is learned i mean everyone has a natural
ability
to some some point but there's people
that i
i knew in high school that really like
did not know how to talk to girls
kind of awkward whenever end up learning
that stuff later in life getting married
or you know getting girl
attractive girlfriend whatever the end
goal was strike up a conversation and if
you're comfortable and you're funny and
it's normal
right and and people will like you so uh
get that out of the way then when when
all these stars are lined and you're
like you know what
finances are great i'm great my shape is
good and you don't have to have all
these perfect before you get started
i'm just saying that's your eventual
goal yeah then when you say you know
what
it's time for me to meet a woman you're
at your best advantage
you say i i'm comfortable talking to
strangers rejection doesn't hurt me
i'm in the best peak physical shape i
probably can't i'm not going to look any
prettier than i am and you know what
you're still going to get rejected
probably
nine times out of ten at least have the
castle built that's it because i always
say women don't build they move in guys
especially in today's day
oh definitely and we sell the time we
become the highest bidder right if you
know for a fact if you ask girls out
you're going to get 100
um flick rate then guess what improve
yourself physically right mentally
and financially so that you have your
best option now she said you know what
rather than date tommy that's broke like
a dick jerry that's actually do
something with his life right yeah
there's no way around it guys you gotta
yeah this is really girls really care if
you have your [ __ ] together
and i know a lot of guys want girls that
just like love them for them
and but it's not even about the money
necessarily a lot of times
if you can sell a girl that you have a
plan and a drive and that you're
actually doing something every day
to achieve that goal that's that's
what's attractive to women
and the big difference the big
difference between your message and mind
we
we both talk up to that point the only
difference i say is look at the laws
look at
marriage look at guys getting falsely
accused of stuff
look how much energy you have to put in
look at some of the prizes you get here
like the the women that you talk to here
i mean yeah you may you may be able to
score with them yeah yeah but if you
actually
are worth no relationships yeah you're
definitely not dating them so if you're
not out there just to hit and quit it
it's kind of like
i know some of you gents are there's
nothing wrong with that but if you're
actually like you know what i'm a mature
dude like i'd like someone to share some
like i want a relationship
but but without that you're still good
to go you
i just say maybe it's not worth wasting
your time you say
well if you're gonna go for it here's
how we'll help you other than that the
road's the same it's just the fork at
the last 10 feet
absolutely because i feel like deep down
let's be real here guys want to get laid
like of course no no matter what they
care about where are you going you want
to get all the kids
maybe at your age when you get older
it's like how's my bitcoin doing how's
my bank account
this is i like him he's so much
he's really showing a different type of
guy like
the guys that i see on these podcasts
and whatever it was very like
macho very obviously players and
this is what i've been trying to say is
not all guys are
like that and not all
and it's not necessarily about money
because i i grew up around very wealthy
people that really were not into that
lifestyle did not drink
did not party did not smoke and
they're like with one woman and happy
you know you but
but i agree with you wait till
testosterone takes a little bit of a
breather
yeah okay cool guys um
i think all of those tips were like
pretty helpful for men
i would agree let me know in the
comments what tips you guys have
for guys if they want to like level up
so to speak
and comment if you guys think i got
anything wrong
or any other thoughts you have don't
forget to subscribe
bye guys